hello ants welcome to the Daily I'm Neil
Patterson and you find me in our
Westminster studio in the heart of
Central London where I think it's fair
to say the excitement is building people
have a spring in their step there's
there's a certain something in the air
the bunting is all around us the reason
of course the local elections are on
Thursday and everyone everyone myself
included can't wait well look I know one
person who is absolutely Cockapoo that's
our Deputy political editor Sam Coates
so I'm not being nasty here but you
don't you do love this kind of thing
don't you
um yes because we spend 364 days a year
kind of trying to work out how things
are going down and and it's a and it's a
really important moment where voters
Mark politicians homework voters
actually Mark our homework have we
gotten the mood right here at Sky are we
a bit off of things happening in the
country that we're not quite sure about
it it it's quite a sobering period okay
well just in terms of what is happening
in Thursday we should probably be a
little bit more specific we're not
seeing any elections in Scotland we're
not seeing locals in Northern Ireland or
indeed Wales it is just England
excluding London and a couple of the big
Metropolitan hubs but there are still
what masses of sea salt programs that's
right so what's going on is that this is
a set of Elections that last took place
in this constellation in 2019 and it's
unitary authorities and District
councils effectively seven out of ten
English voters are going to be able to
go to the polls in one form of Council
election or another
a lot an awful lot it is and it um
although there aren't elections in
London most other parts of the country
have uh some kind of uh some kind of
ballot so it is an important electoral
test and you've got to remember what
happened just a year ago the last time
we had an electoral test Boris Johnson
was prime minister uh we hadn't had uh
the kind of extraordinary economic
turmoil the extraordinary political
turmoil we were two prime ministers ago
Neil
um and the world has changed and we are
trying to work out how all the main
political leaders are gonna fare in you
know a new status quo that we've only
had for a matter of months and so it's a
really big moment for kirst armor is the
momentum behind him so he can get an
extraordinary momentum that he needs in
order to get into number 10 with an
overall majority which would entail the
largest uh swing to the labor party uh
of all time do the conservatives in have
somebody who effectively the
conservative heartlands can trust a bit
more than Boris Johnson and Liz truss
and where on Earth are the liberal
Democrats
um given that we know that they still
got a good by-election fighting machine
but what we don't know under Ed Davey is
whether or not uh they can cut through
and make gains against the conservatives
in the way that the conservatives are
telling us that they're worried about
but we will only really know uh on
Thursday night so so what should we be
looking for there are three metrics that
you can use to judge local elections one
is what happens to Big councils And
there are 230 different councils up for
election uh on Thursday and Tory Council
flipping to a labor council is a really
big moment uh often you'll have this
this like weird phrase no overall
control like a council won't have an
outright majority of one party and the
parties need to work together within
that Council in order to work out a
little bit that you know councils will
go into no overall control go out of no
overall control and we're watching for
that as well so councils is one measure
seats is another measure they're at over
8 000 seats up for grabs uh on uh on
Thursday the conservatives
um still have the the vast lines share
of those seats so that yeah after 2019.
even after 2019 they have they hold the
most so they could potentially lose the
most so that's the second metric
and then the third metric is and this
doesn't come out for a couple of days
that's when they sort of turn the votes
into percentages and what we do is we we
then compare them against the national
opinion polls we work out the swing we
work out whether labor doing anything
like us as well as they should be to um
uh to get the 11 plus they need to to
get into into number 10 with an overall
majority so so three different metrics
and what they do all our friends in in
the political world is there a bit it's
a bit like a magician's trick you know
the magician's Prestige that's the
moment in a magic trick where the
magician gets you to look over there
because the Magic's happening somewhere
else or the problem that they don't want
you to see somewhere else and so if you
use out seat they'll shout out councils
if you shout share of the vote they'll
say that they'll say but but look at
derby
um you for uh viewers and listeners of
of Sky News we're going to try and arm
you as best we can to help you kind of
you know cut through the a spin because
there's an awful lot as you say of
expectation managers bit more aggressive
than I can remember it on the labor side
uh and and so to to know what you're
listening for but always remember there
are three different ways to measure this
stuff and you've got to keep in mind you
know on the night uh that if they're
only talking about one of them ask well
what's happening with the other two so
we will turn to Libra in a second but
but we start with the conservatives
party of government the largest party in
terms of local government as things
stand I mean we have been hearing from I
think it was I think it was the party
term I think it was Greg Hans who
initially said look we are going to lose
a thousand Council seats uh come this
set of local elections that that is what
we are predicting I mean first and
foremost I mean is that fair second I
mean given that they lost an absolute
ton back in 2019 shouldn't this be an
election where they're starting to pick
up again
so the person I'll be listening to quite
literally because he'll be in my ear on
Election night is Michael Thrasher he's
Sky's election analyst he's been doing
the job pretty much as long as I've been
alive and he he does the calculations
upon which we base our analysis and
knows the numbers better than anybody
else he just has he's published books
and books of local election results data
there is no better expert in Britain uh
he's drawn up the benchmarks that we
should um that we should use now he
thinks that a thousand seat losses or
more than a thousands would be really
catastrophically bad
um and it would put them in all
likelihood out of any contention of of
clawing Mac uh some ground before a
general election and would be difficult
750 losses well that's better than the
current polls 500 losses they they might
be able to cast a kind of midterm blues
and and he thinks it'd be quite bad for
the late party if they got anything less
than uh less than
um 300 losses labor really don't like
this set of benchmarks if you listen to
kirst armor interviewed by Sophie Ridge
on Sunday he was arguing that the
conservatives should be gaining seats
now gaining seats isn't anywhere on
Michael Thrasher's benchmarks but they
say that because the Tories did
disastrously in 2019 the last time that
these seats were up that um really it
was so and it was so bad that Theresa
May quit a few weeks later and this was
one of the reasons why that you should
very much expect the conservatives to to
do a bit better get a bit better
and if you look on the kind of
battleground of social media there are a
lot of people are quite critical of of
where Michael sort of set his his expert
his expectation numbers
um but the truth is we need to dig down
into it it you know the the reason why
he's done that is very easy to
understand
in 2019 when you count up all the votes
labor got 31 of the vote Tories got 31
of the vote and you know live dem's got
17. but the two many main parties were
level pegging on 31. now you flipped to
today's opinion polls and the toys are
actually quite a lot less than that so
the Tories are doing worse
um and we've got the same setup and also
when you look at which councils have
have seats up for grabs well it's by Far
and Away the largest party with the most
seats up for grabs are the conservatives
so three and three thousand three
hundred odd seats tall we held seats are
going up for election on Election Day
only 2 100 labor seats ago so
the Tories have gone backwards since
2019 there are many more tool receipts
that could be lost so it stands to
reason I think that in that context you
you can see why we ought to be having a
discussion about losses and perhaps uh
Labor's uh expectation management about
really we should be expecting guys he's
just that and one of the pressures that
the conservatives have had at local
elections in the past has been pressure
from other parties on the right brexit
ukip so on I mean that's that's no
longer the case is it I mean it's there
or nothing that's right in 2019 you know
one of the one of the things that was
was very Stark was that you had a uh a
large you know challenge uh the lib Dems
are on 17 but others were all the way up
on 17
uh uh brexit party back then and ukip on
four percent now all of those kind of
complicating factors have have
disappeared but the other the other
thing is to say labor are doing a lot
better than they did in 2019 and and a
lot of these are straight Laboratory
bites right A lot of these seats so
again if labor are doing massively
better and the Tories are doing a lot
worse then you are going to be in the
territory of Tory losses and so you have
to take with a massive pinch of salt for
labor argument that really we should be
expecting Gates now of course the Tories
are engaging in expectation management
too and a thousand losses even though at
the worst end of Michael Thrasher's
predictions probably uh the Tories are
are are repeating that joyfully because
they know their canvas returns are
suggesting something rather uh rather
less less bad than that but I think that
there is a good argument to say that you
need to judge
um what happens on Thursday night when
it comes to seats by looking it through
the prism of just how many losses the
Tory party are going to get rather than
even considering that they might get
gains so what's one of Lebo then
expected to pick up and pick up
significantly on the basis of what
you've been saying so labor say well we
think that 400 gains would be a pretty
good night for us
now again returning to Michael Thrashers
he he thinks that wouldn't be that
impressive uh 450 gains would be little
Improvement on on last year and so it's
sort of solid-ish but not exceptional
and look we've just got to get back to
that to the core point of where we are
kind of in British politics at the
moment which is labor need to do
exceptionally well to uh to to win at
the uh at the next election now it's
often worth thinking about a swing
omitter
um if there's a Tory to labor swing of
three percent three point two percent
then the Tories all basically no longer
have a majority and and pretty quickly
you you get into kissed on a possibly uh
being uh in power to get to the being
the largest party labor need AIDS 6.97
swing almost seven percent swing now
that's bigger than the one that Margaret
Thatcher achieved in 1979 and then to
get overall majority
um labor needs a 12 swing from the
Tories now that is more that is more
than Tony Blair got not to get one or
two seeds but to get the 179 majority in
1997. in other words because of where
Jeremy corbyn left the labor party in in
2019 and the utterly disastrous worst
performance since the second world war
election defeat that he he took us to
other accounts from some Jeremy corbyn
allies are available what happened that
night but but it was awful in electoral
numbers terms kirst armor has the most
incredible mountain to climb and to get
back he needs to do exceptionally so
400 seats
solid but unexceptional just isn't going
to cut it and would pretty much be
pointing towards a not just a slightly
messy hung pump but a very messy hung
Parliament where he's having to rely
quite a lot on maybe the liberal
Democrats but maybe also the SNP and on
the basis of what you are seeing could
labor could liver actually be the
largest party after all all the dust has
settled I mean that would be a huge huge
achievement it'd be massive massive
piece of symbolism uh it's the first
time that they would be the largest
party in the local government by seats
since 2002. Just To Tot it up at the
moment the labor party have
5823 seats in local government and the
conservative party have
6603 seats in local government now labor
party aren't saying that they're even
aiming for that but you know if the
labor party lost uh gained 400 seats and
the Tories lost 400 seats to one another
we'd pretty much be there and that does
so that doesn't feel impossible so watch
the space
[Music]
what about the others you kept brexit
party and not really playing but of
course we do have the greens and of
course you've already mentioned them the
liberal Democrats now they do do very
well when it comes to these short
campaigns we know they're greater
by-elections they're pretty decent at
local elections as well
there have been good
liberal Democrat uh local election
performances but
um
it's interesting because at a
by-election a party can funnel all of
its resources into one place
and that's been exceptionally
sort of significantly uh successful for
the liberal Democrats in this Parliament
you know you've got a string of
by-election successes uh in the last
couple of years
um sort of unnerving the conservatives
but when you have a local election and
and you're campaigning in you know so
many more different parts of the country
you know the liberal Democrats are
contesting 1 200 seats so that's quite a
lot less than the 3300 of the toys but
still that you're having to fight across
lots of different parts of of the
country you're much more reliant on what
the core message is from your party
leader how much prominence the parties
managed to get
um uh in the media uh and and what the
sort of wedge policy issues what what
things have have cut through and and it
is just a bit harder for the liberal
Democrats at the moment partly because
they have they just have less prominence
than they did when they were the third
biggest party in in British politics
um but also because post 2019 there
isn't quite the clear dividing line on
something like brexit you know they're
not promising to undo it uh there are
some cost of living promises uh but it's
not um there isn't um the sort of single
issue like there was with tuition fees
in 2010 uh the opposition to the Iraq
War in 2005 better public services in
1997. you know there are election
campaigns pre-election campaigns where
you absolutely know what they were doing
what they were what what they were
standing for
um but but not but not perhaps and I'm
sure they shouted me a bit for this but
not perhaps so distinctive this time
that everybody knows that the liberal
Democrats stand for x and and and so if
the national campaigning message is
weaker and your resources are spread a
bit thinner and and Lord sainsbury who
did fund the last general election
campaign for the liberal Democrats does
look like he's funneling his resources
back into
um the labor party and that could leave
quite a big big hole I think that all of
that does mean that they
um you know that that they start with
less of an advantage but the toys are
still worried about them and you know a
good night for them will be 150 seats or
more
um and there are some councils where
they could knock the Tories off um uh
overall control make some progress they
may even knock the toys off their perch
in Windsor which is of course you know
it's a maidenhead territory you know
home of the king just a kind of place
that you were absolutely associate with
being true blue I mean we were talking
earlier about um Theresa May and I
totally forgotten the fact that one of
the one of the things one of the reasons
that her departure was ushered Usher
then was was of course the local
election results look I mean really soon
like it seems to me is embedded in
number 10 until the next general
election I'm wondering if you feel the
same no matter how this goes I mean if
it is as disastrous as Greg hand
suggested I mean the there will be
knives out for him
um I what's been fascinating about the
last five months of British politics is
is the degree to which
um the conservative party has decided to
self-stabilize a little bit
um and and if I'm being honest more than
I expected so a couple of things have
been quite key he managed to bring the
penalty together over brexit now that's
a difficult sentence to have imagined
saying six months ago but but he did
he's looked more polished more grown up
uh than uh Liz truss currently fighting
over whether or not she nicked bathrobes
from
one of the grace and favor mentions and
Boris Johnson he's about upon whose
verdict whether or not he lied in his
resignation on this list and whether or
not he's going to put his dad in the
Lord you know like I think all all of
that is um is is very consciously in the
in the in the background and the toys
have United a bit more and decided that
maybe if they if they kind of line up
behind rishi's a bit more chance of of
winning and the and the job of the labor
party is to go hang on this is a a
conservative party that has ended up
having a prime minister uh who's been at
the beck and call of a party that has
wanted wild and wacky and wonderful
things for the last 13 years don't let
that continue and driving that message
home so the bottom line is no I don't
expect even if these results are bad uh
Richard's doing that to have a
particularly difficult uh time after
that I think the problems that he will
face come around the fact that he's got
pretty clear campaigning messages and
campaigning targets and there's five
there's five pledges but they're
someone go out to deliver and I think
that's his next big problem
um I actually think that the the the
biggest thing in this election is a sort
of is an all-round 360 kind of
multi-dimensional test of kirst armor
and the labor party yeah and in
particular if you know
if there are bits of the results that
allow people to claim that you just
don't quite have the momentum that you
really need to get that overall majority
because the mountain is so high how they
all cope with that and
um I I think you can often judge quite
with quite a lot of insight into the
real metal of a political party uh in
the kind of few days after a local
election uh I always love the moment the
polls close in the next five days after
that rather than an election campaign
campaigns are a bit dreary because
everyone stays on message most of the
time they're also incredibly tiring it's
not okay yeah no and you know Kirsten
had horrendous 2021 a pretty good 2022
and it's just going to be interesting to
watch whether this politician who who
would fully admit to you in private that
he's been learning on the job it could
handle a nuanced story uh of solid
positive advance but not spectacular
with people wanting spectacular you know
how do they how do they capitalize on
that and I think watching that will be
the most interesting thing from Thursday
night onwards
I mean three places that you might are
just to keep an eye on I mean I'm I'm
having a careful look I would say
Plymouth Darlington
um both looking to go labor from nor
control I think I think those will be
interesting to keep an eye on myself
um Swindon absolutely key general
election area at the moment that's
conservative control you gov have it
leading Labor uh it just is a great you
know Bellwether place to to keep an eye
on
Derby
now Derby is the scene of son of kirst
Armor's greatest local election
disasters particularly in in 2021 it has
gone uh they lost it completely back
then
um he needs to be doing better in the
West Midlands and then
um anywhere around the teas Valley and
Darlington places like that's at the
moment Darlington has no overall control
but the Hugo projection has has labor
making big gains and and now it's
leaning low but so those those are some
of the places that I'm watching I think
um you've asked about cancels I'm going
to come back to my very first point
there are three ways in which you can
judge late elections seats does the
conservative party lose its tag of
largest party uh in local government and
labor rotate them uh councils we've just
gone through and then vote chat which
you don't get inconveniently for 48
hours until after closer result those
are the three ways if a politician then
he talks about one none of them about
the other two I certainly will Sam
anything well that is your luck for
today but we do have a special episode
due out on Friday afternoon when we
should have all the results and we'll be
unpacking everything you need to know so
just set a reminder for that one my
thanks again to Sam coats and of course
to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Neil Patterson this
episode was produced by Emery Woodhouse
our editor is Philly moment